there are nations that are interfering
russia is one of them
it uses a variety of tactics to do this
including
this internet research agency which is
this you know infamous troll farm that
exists in st
petersburg russia um and basically their
job is to
influence the discourse of a bunch of
countries um two main targets have been
of course the united states and ukraine
and as a result you know they are
manipulating our discourse using the
loopholes in the fabric of the internet
and social media and exploiting
our very openness and democracy which is
i think it's one of our weaknesses it's
both our strength and our weakness the
fact that we are open and transparent
means that they can get in the discourse
and as a result
we are seeing our own societal fissures
turned on their heads and manipulated in
order to drive us against one another
and decrease engagement in the
democratic process
i'm joined by nina jankowicz nina
welcome to the show
thanks so much for having me chris
pleasure to have you on
is russia listening to this podcast oh
wow
probably oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you know i sent a couple copies of my
book to to friends and journalists in
moscow and they never arrived so i
i only assume that they're at least
listening to some of the podcast
appearances i've made
bloody hell so where do we start
let's let's lay the land for people who
don't know
the what the ira is oh think that the
ira is like the terrorist
cell in in ireland yeah i get that a lot
yeah
what do you mean the ira are they
getting involved they were quite
militant i didn't think they would get
involved in internet troll
so like that's bot farms and russia like
what what's going on at the moment
sure uh well at the moment nothing is
very different from
from what it was in 2016. there are
nations that are interfering
russia is one of them it uses a variety
of tactics to do this
including uh this internet research
agency which is this
you know infamous troll farm that exists
in st petersburg russia
it's headed up by an oligarch
is his last name who uh also owns some
catering companies and he
also does like uh fake army people for
hire that he sent to the central african
republic and a bunch of other places but
he's known as putin's chef
because of his catering businesses and
he also set up this troll farm
uh where they have a couple hundred
people working and we know this thanks
to great reporting from
uh from russians and and folks who were
whistleblowers at the ira
um and basically their job is to
influence the discourse of a bunch of
countries um two main targets have been
of course the united states
and ukraine especially after the illegal
annexation of the crimean peninsula in
2014
and ukraine was kind of the ira's
laboratory that's where they tested a
lot of the tactics
and at the same time we're trying them
out here in the united states
uh we know that they bought 100 000
worth of facebook ads in 2016. uh
that kind of was able to slip under the
rug but um
you know we've gotten a little bit wiser
i hope at least the social media firms
are are looking for that sort of
manipulation
but russia doesn't stop right we've
given them no real
cost we've imposed no cost uh to make
them really disengage from this activity
and certainly the uk hasn't either the
russia report just came out last week
and and we learned that the uk
government has kind of dropped the ball
on this issue
um and as a result you know bad actors
be they russia or china or iran or
venezuela
they are manipulating our discourse
using the loopholes in the fabric of the
internet and social media and exploiting
our very openness and democracy which
kind of
is i think you know it's one of our
weaknesses it's both our strength and
our weakness the fact that we are open
and transparent
um means that they can get in the
discourse the fact that we have you know
the first amendment here in the united
states and we want to value freedom of
speech and of expression we're very
hesitant to touch any of that
kind of pernicious uh spurious content
that might be online and
as a result um we are seeing our own
societal fissures turned on their heads
and
and manipulated in order to drive us
against one another and
decrease engagement in the democratic
process and we're only 98 days
away from an election right now here in
the states [ __ ]
hell it's just it's just
it doesn't sound good it's the the
synopsis is it doesn't sound very good
okay so
we have professional catfish fake news
bot farm
disinformation misinformation that is
far more sophisticated than anyone could
have imagined coming out of a country
that
looks like it's only just discovered the
wheel but actually is crazy
sophisticated
and also plays to the fact that it feels
like this sort of backwards bludgeoning
fool
is kind of like tumbling through the
world circuit and actually is really
really
adept at this stuff um it's happening
from multiple different countries
the how is varied and we're going to get
into that
the what is nuanced and we're going to
get into that
and the result is fractured society
people not believing in
diplomacy and uh democracy
and increasing um pulls to either end
which tear at the fabric of the middle
yes yes that's exactly right that's
because i read the book
i read the book and then i was able to
just tell you what you wrote and now i
sound like i'm an expert on it that's
what i'm an expert on it
so where do we begin is it the is it the
what they're doing is it the how they're
doing it
i think the how they're doing it is more
instructive actually so
um i had a little bit of a tiff with my
publisher about the subtitle of the book
they
they really wanted it to be russia fake
news and the future of conflict which
you will uh
you will see that it did end up that way
um
but i i pushed back against fake news
being in the subtitle because
while it is a signpost to most
normal people who don't think about this
for their job like i do
uh it's a it's a misnomer most
disinformation
many of the information operations that
have been most effective both coming
from russia
and you know the domestic stuff that
we're dealing with isn't about cut and
dry
fakes it's not about you know uh a fake
article about something hillary clinton
did
or something trump did it's stuff that
plays on our emotions
that's the currency of disinformation
and russia is very adept at identifying
that so
they they look for fishers in our
society
and in the united states we have many of
them that is by virtue of the fact that
we are a large country we
uh we have a lot of you know cleavages
in our society ethnic racial
economic that can be exploited and
certainly our discourse has become more
and more polarized
and they just identify those hot button
issues and kind of poke at them
from from either side of the spectrum
and that's the second misconception
right
a lot of people think okay you know
russia wanted the uk to leave the
european union
uh russia wanted trump to be in the
white house because that's beneficial to
russia
both of those things are true but that
doesn't mean that they were
only kind of agitating on behalf of
those causes they were agitating on on
both
sides of the spectrum so pro-leave
prolimate remain
pro-trump pro-clinton well they really
didn't ever do any pro-clinton stuff but
they did do pro sanders
and jill stein um and and the idea again
is to just
flood the zone with with information so
much that people disengage
they get people who are engaged to turn
against one another
and all of that benefits moscow because
it means that our democracies are
in shambles that we're not able to reach
consensus which is one of the most
important things about
politics and creating a functioning
government uh it means that government
is less responsive and that's great for
putin he can point to that and say to
russians you know
is that the sort of democracy you want
is that why you're on the streets right
now no you want something stable
you want order and that's what i'm
giving you here in russia it also means
that you know
russia's status is uh is definitely
increased in the world is there a time
since 2016 where
the united states hasn't been going on
and on about russia every day there's
there's at least one russia related
disinformation article not to mention
all the other stuff that they've been
doing which of course we've been kind of
ignoring
right because we're so concerned with
this we're so concerned with what's
going on at home all that's great for
putin
how do we define or how do we identify
the difference
between russian or
um malignant malign actor
instantiated news
which is making people not want to
engage with the discourse
and uh domestic based
news because it seems like the tactics
that russia's using here which is
uh divisive um encouraging people to
disengage with talking online and stuff
like that
seems like we're doing a pretty good job
of that ourselves
and the fact that i can say that
sentence makes me think
where's the line yeah yeah you're
absolutely right and that's actually one
of the main points of the book
so i went out and did this reporting in
five countries in central and eastern
europe thinking like okay i'm gonna
write a lot about russian disinformation
but really the main point
is that you can't fight russian
disinformation or chinese disinformation
or what have you
if you're not addressing domestic
disinformation as well
we need to understand that
disinformation no matter its vector
is a threat to democracy and uh that's
something that we've really not
not gotten to here in the united states
i think there is a disincentive to tell
the truth in our politics lately if you
are telling the truth
you are absolutely on the back foot
compared to the people who are using the
russian playbook
uh on their own citizens and and we've
seen a lot of that here there are other
countries in the book i talk about
namely poland where that has been
playing out
there you couldn't have a country that
understands the russian threat more than
poland
and and yet uh they're doing so little
to address it because they're
they're kind of enveloped in the
domestic disinformation
scheme at home and you can't have it
both ways you just can't
um and that's where kind of the
regulation question comes into play
nobody's really answered that question
yet um but
but really the rules need to apply to
everybody no matter the vector
of that disinformation this sounds and
some people listening
may be thinking this just sounds like
crazy conspiracy theory like right let's
get our tinfoil hats out nina's chatting
again
um what are some of the explicit
examples that you came up with or your
favorite examples from the book on some
of the
times that stuff has occurred due to
russia's input
sure so my favorite one for a couple of
reasons one
it demonstrates that it's not just a
republican thing disinformation here in
the united states it can be a liberal
thing too so that's one reason it's
great it also happened
after the 2016 election so interference
still going on
uh even after these revelations came to
light and three it shows the fact that
well actually four things let me edit
myself through
four things so three shows the fact that
homegrown actors are are used in these
campaigns a lot
and four shows that it has a real life
impact
uh when we move kind of out of the
offline space so irl as the kids would
say right
um this is the story of ryan clayton
and americans take action and the july
4th
2017 les miserables flash mob that they
held
in front of the white house so uh i was
in october of 2018 actually coming home
from the uk i got off a transatlantic
flight and turned my phone on
as i was making my way through customs
in washington
and uh i got a flurry of text messages
about a new
part of the mueller investigation the
russian investigation that had just been
unsealed it was a criminal complaint
detailing how the ira
operated how they made their money how
they spent it
and in that complaint they detailed a
few instances
where the ira was spending money on
events in in the dc area across
the country one of them was a musical
theater show tunes flash mob and it's
really funny
that that was included in there because
i had seen ads for this event
i do theater in my spare time which i
don't have a lot of anymore
but i had been served this ad it was
like come dress up like a colonist on
on july 4th and sing less and demand
trump's impeachment in front of the
white house like i remembered this ad
so i got really excited and i started
reaching out to all my theater friends
and being like
i actually was out of the country at
that point in 2017 but i was like did
you guys go to this because i remembered
people posting about it
couldn't find any of my friends who went
but there were videos online
um and so i reached out to the guy this
guy ryan clayton he's in his 30s he's
kind of a hipster he's a progressive
activist
and i found him in the videos and said
ryan did you know that the
internet research agency bought 80 worth
of ads
in order to turn more people out to your
protests
and i think his response was holy [ __ ]
thank you for letting us know they had
no idea and they were they they weren't
explicitly mentioned in the complaint
they were kind of referred to as like
organization one or something like that
um but then i met him later for coffee
and he told me all about his background
as a progressive
activist um and he he's the one that
said
what you were referencing before you
know uh it's not about a specific world
view it's about
pulling at the fabric of society on the
sides
so that it rips down the middle um and i
just think this is such a great example
of the fact that you know russia doesn't
create this stuff
it often uses local conduits it happens
in real life it has a real life
impact he thinks that was one of their
most successful protests because
of those ads they were so well targeted
um
and you know it kept going after 2016.
it's just staggering to me
so it's not like russia ascending over
spies
or there's a bunch of russians taking
off their little sort of fez hats
and then donning like hippie elephant
pants and going outside of the white
house
well they're not we don't know that for
sure the internet research agency did
send a couple of employees over to do
kind of a reconnaissance mission and i
think
2014 or 2015 but no it's not like
uh fsb agents are coming from the the
russian embassy
they're actually yeah which is the best
part you should watch the videos they're
really
uh really inspiring um but uh
yeah it's it's more about using people
who are already
uh expressing these viewpoints
identifying them
um and amplifying them and that's what's
still happening today
right you know we've gotten a little bit
better at detecting those fake ads
facebook doesn't allow those for the
most part to be bought anymore
but russia continues its information
laundering
using those authentic local voices to
deliver or amplify a
divisive message sometimes wittingly
sometimes unwittingly
there was a cnn investigation in march
that broke the fact that the internet
research agency had contracted with pr
firms in ghana and nigeria to spread its
messaging
um kind of pro black lives matter
messaging in the united states so they
have that conduit
but that's one of the witting examples
we have unwitting examples all the time
of you know fringe outlets
unknowingly amplifying russian
narratives or
uh russian-based content that sort of
thing or narratives on on fringe outlets
that
deliberately take stuff from rt and
sputnik or
or other russian propaganda sources so
it's complicated and then there's
you know money involved as well um
illicit finance and how
uh networks of organizations and
political parties are supporting all of
those narratives
to lend credence to them and they're
supported by the russian government
it's like the enemy of my enemy is my
friend i suppose unfortunately and if
you as someone on one side of the aisle
permits something
some disinformation or misinformation to
go ahead
because you know that it's going to
damage the person that's on the other
side of the aisle
you kind of you are a little bit
complicit have you got any idea
if and if so how much they've been
involved over the last few months has
there been any
rumors about how much they've got
involved in the recent black lives
matter
protests and stuff like that well
it's hard to track these campaigns in
real time especially because the
platforms don't give us
back end access so what we do have is
based on twitter which
everybody knows that twitter's not real
life um and
facebook you know we kind of have to do
guesswork so it's hard to identify this
stuff in real time and they're not
creating those same
fake accounts the way that they used to
um
all that being said if you look at the
kind of overt propaganda that russia
puts out on
our team sputnik and similar uh similar
you know outlets like rupt lee which is
a subsidiary of rt there's a whole bunch
of like smaller video outlets that
russia uses
um they've certainly taken a really
critical
view of the us during these protests
which like honestly we deserve it
um we have been harassing and and and
beating
protesters and journalists and i it's
it's hard to
think about how we have two legs to
stand on when it comes to talking about
human rights abuses and things like that
when that sort of thing
is happening here and that's that's
perfect for russia it's ready-made
disinformation um in terms of broader
campaigns that have been going on
again really hard to track but we do
know that senate
and house democrats have been demanding
a briefing from the fbi
related to foreign interference in the
2020 election
and the intelligence community just last
week released an assessment that said
it was basically a warning to american
citizens saying a bunch of different
actors are trying to influence the
election
russia is one of them china is one of
them but we're really concerned about
russia
especially related to cyber issues we
know that russia for instance is hacking
vaccine trials for covet 19.
um but uh they
the senate and and house democrats say
that that wasn't enough
and we need more detail about the types
of campaigns that are going on so
americans know what to look out for and
what what information to trust
frankly of course that gets really
politicized again because any
discussion of russian interference is
automatically viewed as an indictment of
trump's legitimacy
um and that's really really unfortunate
no one
is okay people are claiming that trump
is is not a legitimate president i am
not one of them
uh i just want to make sure that you
know
we are protecting our discourse and and
that people have the tools they need to
navigate the information environment
we're in i it's not a political issue
for me right now
talk me through the life of an ira agent
how many people do you work with what
what's you turn up to work
you sit down at your desk you learn
about america what do you do do you
read a bit about america come up with a
funny meme about donald trump
send it out spend a bit of like boost
the post and then leave it like
what are they doing talk me through what
their how many people work there and
where it is and stuff
yeah i don't know if we have an updated
number about how many work there
anymore it used to be a couple hundred
uh they since moved their headquarters
and we don't know where they are
anymore i mean maybe somebody in the
intelligence community does but i don't
know
um and they have these different
departments the america department
is a lot of former journalists
especially young people who
have good knowledge of english they have
good knowledge of american culture which
is frankly a lot of russians they
have law order reruns constantly on in
russia for instance
uh they consume a lot of american
culture
um i think they're consuming a little
bit of american media watching the
trends in the information space they
have some guidance about issues that
they should be pressing and
what candidates they should be
supporting and what they should be
kind of denigrating um but ultimately i
would describe the approach
as spaghetti at the wall um they are
they are throwing spaghetti at the wall
they are seeing what sticks and then
they are continually throwing that same
sticky piece of pasta
at that same spot on the wall because
they know it works and social media
allows them to do that so anybody who's
ever bought a facebook ad or
or you know promoted anything on twitter
or google
understands the level of targeting data
you have you can really a b
test things to see what is resonating
with people
and it's just a ready-made kind of
disinformation laser gun
but they have to figure out what works
first and so if you look through the
russian ads from 2016 that
the house democrats released in 2018
it's
it's not necessarily all like bang on
super successful
engaging content some of it's really
weird and that's because they were
testing things right some of them have
no engagement at all
um it's just totally out of left field
and i think that's what's really
interesting about it the other
interesting thing is that they
understand that you can't just
hit people over the head with with you
know false or misleading information
right away you kind of have to earn
their trust
uh because people are still even today i
think a little bit skeptical of new
information they encounter online
and so the campaigns look like community
building
originally they start with content
that's uh
you know if we're talking about the
black lives matter movement um
content that is about black history or
like positive contributions of black
americans
to uh society and then after
a couple months if not a couple of years
of that it moves on to stuff that is
a little bit more political so asking
people to change their profile picture
in support of a cause asking them to
sign an online petition
asking them to turn up in real life to
protest and it's really ingenious the
way that that works
they've also identified as i mentioned
before uh different activists who
are passionate legitimate activists and
looking for
just some extra support so if somebody
comes to you and says i want to buy you
some ads for your protest
as ryan clayton from americans take
action told me he was like
well as long as they're not politicians
for killing puppies then like yeah i'm
gonna take your money
um because it's important to me to get
my my cause across and
i think that's the sort of thing that's
happening and especially because
facebook in particular um is using
groups
now as such an important part of its
platform in a way to engage
users um that is
uh that's where we're seeing a lot of
this really really
scary information being shared because
there's less
uh oversight there and these are closed
spaces
oh god i just keep on thinking that how
much of the stuff that i see online
is created by some fella sat in the ira
um what are some of the ads
that they ran during 2016 that were
either
some of the ones that were effective and
some of the hilarious ones that were
ineffective can you remember any of
those
yeah um my favorite one is this golden
retriever
who i i love dogs i have a dog he's
actually quite famous he was on
an npr once national public radio here
in
dc yeah he he howls along to the theme
song of one of their evening news shows
so he's a famous dog
uh this other dog perhaps not so famous
this dog didn't do that well
uh in the ads he's a golden retriever
he's kind of sat in a little field
his paws are crossed he's got a red and
white star bandana on and he's holding a
little american flag between his paws
obviously this was photoshopped uh and
it says on the picture
like if you think it's gonna be a great
week um
which i probably wouldn't like that
because
i don't know if you if you wouldn't like
that you don't have a soul
exactly right or you hate america which
like
fine fine maybe maybe you don't think uh
the dog should be holding
a flag maybe that's animal abuse i'm not
sure but
uh so that was one of their kind of more
positive ads that was shared on the
being patriotic
facebook page um there were other ones
that were about
beyonce it was like you know trying to
come for queen bae as we call her uh
kind of i don't know criticizing her
there was like a dance-off post about
beyonce
uh there were some things that
encouraged
again on the being patriotic page that
encouraged
uh trump supporters to dress their kids
up in
make america great again gear and take
pictures of them and then they were
gonna there was a contest and whoever
got the most likes would
i forget what the thing was but they it
that scares me because it's using kids
and they're putting their images on the
internet
um what else was there there was uh
this duo of um two
black guys in russia who made content
for youtube
this never took off they basically just
made content targeted at the
american black community um and it was
just basically talking about police
brutality and stuff like that but they
weren't
they weren't from america they were from
from i forget which african country
living in russia clearly uh targeting
black americans and it just it's
nevertheless one of the slightly less
subtle
approaches yeah
i mean daniel and this is like yeah
they just weren't well produced i mean
there's something to say for
infotainment which russia is really good
at
and if you are interested in this i
would recommend peter pomeranzev's book
nothing is true and everything is
possible he worked as a tv producer in
russia in the 90s which
was a crazy time to be in russia and he
talks about
you know all these slickly produced
things that they're so good at
um this was not one of them it doesn't
seem like it it also seems like they've
read gary vaynerchuk's jab jab jab right
hook
where it's like oh i just keep on giving
you some of this it's a dog it's just a
dog with a bandana
this this and this and then we just sign
this petition
the thing that makes me feel the most
uncomfortable is when it starts
to move from virtual to reality like
when people are going and doing a thing
um yeah you know you feel like there's a
boundary
some sort of um sphere within which
things can happen and as long as it's
on the internet kind of doesn't matter
when it gets into real world it does
was it um did russia have the biggest
black divist facebook page
before they were bigger than black lives
matter and it was russia
exactly right yeah blacktivist was the
name of the page uh and it had more
facebook followers than black lives
matter and the the race component of all
of russia's engagement was probably the
the strongest and most successful
component um on
on both sides of the coin both the
racist and the anti-racist side of the
coin
um but particularly uh targeted at black
americans and trying to get them to to
disengage and not come out to vote
what does it say that the biggest like
black activist page
on the internet wasn't domestically
owned
russia had control over an increasingly
divisive inflammatory topic
it's not surprising actually russia's
been really good at using race for this
stuff for decades in fact
um they don't have any black people how
do they even know how race works
well actually russia has a hundred
different ethnicities russians will tell
you that
and none of them are black they do have
some muslims though
yeah so uh but they during the soviet
union in fact
um one of the big elements of soviet
propaganda was that there was no racism
in the soviet union and that
black americans should feel comfortable
to travel to the soviet union where they
would be treated as equals it was
it was one of their main calling cards
and i i took a soviet film class um
my first year of undergrad and we
watched this movie called
circus and you can find this online i i
can send it to you as well
to include in the show notes but there's
the end of this movie
basically this american circus performer
comes to russia
on a tour uh there's this evil guy who's
kind of her manager he finds out that
she has a black baby
um and this is she thinks this is going
to be a huge scandal he thinks it's
going to ruin her career
and it turns out at the end that this
you know cornucopia of soviet peoples in
front of which
she's performing just accept the baby
and the ending of the film is them
passing the baby around
singing him a lullaby in all of their
like native languages
and native garb their ethnic garb which
i mean there's a there's a lot of ethnic
problems in in russia and the former
soviet space
a lot of racism against people who are
not
uh visibly white so it's and
i've had black friends uh who have
encountered a lot of this as well so
it's
it's bs hogwash um but they're very good
at using this and very practiced at
using this in the american context and
of course like
again it's not something that they
really have to create america has an
endemic racism problem
and unfortunately there are people who
don't want to admit that and so their
prime target and then the people who are
you know passionately
fighting for social justice and racial
justice are also targets for the reasons
that we discussed before because they're
actively working and really want to get
something done here
it must feel as an activist of a
worthy cause in your mind that's just
doing your thing and i just learned some
stuff online man and
you know i read this blog post and
watched this video and now i'm out here
doing my bit for the cause
like to find out that that cause
was falsely created by
someone from a country on the opposite
side of the planet
i i don't know what that
says in a meta ethics term for what the
truth is that that person believes in
does that push them closer to a truth
that they
wouldn't have known otherwise is it
unfair to tell
someone something that makes them act in
a way when you're not from the country
and you have a different
do you know what i mean like you can get
kind of quite abstract with thinking
about
whether it's justified or not to further
a cause which at its essence might have
um veracity and truth but isn't being
done for the right reasons does that
make sense
yeah so i think the difference is like
russia's not creating this stuff it's
exploiting it
so i don't blame the activists at all
right i think they are doing their
intentions are pure and
it's it there's nobody should take
action against them
for unknowingly engaging in this stuff
they have no
no and no one really has to their credit
i think um
it's worth educating activists and kind
of members of civil society
about the fact that you can't trust
everybody you meet on the internet
actually i think this is worthwhile for
everybody to understand especially those
of us who are active in like facebook
groups and stuff you know i
i give the example a lot that just
because you're in a group of local moms
uh doesn't mean that everybody there is
actually a local mom and if you've not
met them or been on the phone with them
in person
like face to face or in person like on
the audio jeez i can't talk um
then then you know if you have reason to
believe that they
aren't who they say they are um and in
fact a lot of the activists who
were being manipulated by russia they
tried to get them on the phone and they
could never get anybody on the phone and
they kind of just gave up and were like
all right
like whatever we're doing this we're
doing this action we're doing this rally
it is what it is um and i think that's a
red
flag these days and we just have to we
have to be careful about it um and there
are going to be
people who aren't going to care about
that on both sides of the spectrum
they're just going to say
i'm fine with taking that money i don't
care you know i'm still this is this is
what i believe in
um and that's where we need some
regulation you know there are rules
about
foreign money in elections uh there's
there are going to be i hope soon rules
about foreign influence online
uh related to political issues and and
everybody needs to kind of increase
their awareness of the fact that
there are people manipulating the the
online discourse across the spectrum
inside and outside of our borders why
did the russians want trump
in office well they hate clinton
they really really loads of people hated
her well
there it was kind of personal with putin
and clinton
he saw her as personally responsible for
protests that happened in
2012 that were probably the biggest
check on his legitimacy in office
um that he had ever faced he he saw
those protests as funded by the united
states and
organized by the united states even
though they weren't um so
so and she was pretty tough on him uh
and it was clear that her administration
was going to be tough on him
trump on the other hand uh has a soft
spot for authoritarians
um had publicly questioned whether
uh crimea should be part of ukraine or
part of russia uh
just you know cliff notes it's part of
ukraine like it's ukraine's sovereign
territory for anyone wondering
and we don't allow countries to just
rewrite borders anymore
um he he has a lot of connections to
uh russian organized crime uh he a lot
of the tenants in his condos and his
buildings were
russian oligarchs still are because he's
not divested himself from it from any of
those holdings
so i think um in short putin
knew he would be easy to manipulate and
i think that's proven true
we've not imposed any costs any
significant costs
on the russian regime for the things
that they've done
not only in regard to disinformation but
vis-a-vis ukraine vis-a-vis syria um
there's any number of
of things we could have been harsher on
uh and
for some reason trump has kind of just
allowed that stuff to happen
uh without any check or even worse his
administration has imposed costs in
other parts of government be it the
state department or treasury imposing
sanctions on certain russians
and then trump has come in and kind of
undercut a lot of that he's
just created this kind of incongruity
between what his administration
does and then the things he says to
putin and he talks to putin on the phone
all the time we never get readouts from
what those calls say
beyond like very very broad things um
and you know he's been publicly very
positive
about his relationship with putin he he
jokes with putin about
election interference he he wags his
finger and says don't you meddle in our
elections
which i don't know that's not the
warning that i as an american citizen
want to see
uh trump giving putin and there's
nothing i want more than for us to have
great relations with
with russia probably under a different
leader right
um i love the russian people i lived
there i love
many russians a lot of them were at my
wedding right it it's not about
russophobia it's about rules of the
international order
and like democratic and human rights
norms that we seem to have abandoned
for reasons that i can't fully explain
unless i were able to get into trump's
brain
yeah i understand it seems at the moment
listening to a lot of stuff
that comes from joe rogan's podcast also
ben shapiro's stuff
um i've got chris voss from the fbi i've
got him on soon and
some of the stuff that i've heard him
talk about it seems like china is like
china's the hot new girl in school to be
worried about as an international power
and it almost feels a little bit to me
like
russia was the old
fear for a long time right cold war then
that kind of gets artifacted across then
the ussr
kind of break down and all that sort of
stuff happens and then
the we kind of forget about about russia
a little bit
and then was all these concerns about
hawaii
and about um trademarking and there's
these
markets in china that are making
duplicates of like every car on the
planet
and then the uk government only last
month said that they're going to roll
back the integration of 5g
towers that are being provided by china
because of concerns for security and
stuff like that
so are you are you team russia for who
we need to be more worried about
i think we can be worried about both at
once and that's actually what makes it a
much more difficult challenge right when
you've got multiple very strong
adversaries in the international arena
that are both
screwing with you in different ways uh i
think that's
that's a really challenging scenario how
do you distinguish the two
what's the what's the relative roles
that they're both playing
sure with the caveat that i am you know
all of my background is in is in russia
and russian studies
um and i'm you know i just read about
china but the way that
i understand it is um china
has always practiced disinformation and
propaganda to some extent
with the online stuff they've just
started to dip their toes into the type
of things that russia has been doing and
still
the the goal of chinese disinformation
isn't necessarily
to uh to pull the fabric of society
apart like we were talking about before
it's to promote china as a world power
it's to promote
the chinese kind of narrative the
chinese view of the world
uh and and of course to denigrate the
united states
and other western powers um russia has
its own kind of masochistic
uh unscrupulous goals that that differ
in that way and then in terms of tactics
russia's gotten really good
at the manipulation of those fissures
whereas china
is is still just using kind of overt
propaganda and that's the most
successful thing for them so
they're using diplomatic accounts um
state-run propaganda channels uh overt
messengers to send a coordinated message
across
you know many different information
environments in the west and elsewhere
um and if they're using fake accounts
they've not done a very good job of it
so there have been some analyses of like
how china during the first wave of hong
kong protests how
china was trying to influence the
rhetoric and dialogue about
what was going on there and it was all
really heavy-handed
stuff that just i mean i think nobody
really bought into it
i i wouldn't put it past them that
they're gonna get better at it and and
they do use disinformation really of
course
very effectively uh on their domestic
population um they have what's called
the tencent army which is this
army full of commenters who comment on
public posts on blogs and like wechat
and things like that
um to that's like pro ccp propaganda
and so if that if those folks spoke you
know other languages and were unleashed
on the world we'd have ourselves a
problem but for some reason
they've not done that yet and and i
think part of that's because they have
kind of a technical leg up and certainly
a
an economic leg up in ways that russia
doesn't
um they don't they don't need to engage
in that sort of cheap easy return on
investment
stuff because they have so many levers
in
diplomatic and economic negotiations
that
russia certainly in the economic realm
does not
so that's where i see the difference um
and i think they're again
both both problems for
uh coming at us in different vectors and
um
we we're going to need people in
government who understand both of these
countries
we're going to need people who
understand the tools and tactics that
they're using
and and people who are willing to you
know look at the problems
um that both of these nations are
exploiting at home whether that's
u.s economic insecurity or societal
issues
um and and you know strengthen uh
the domestic situation which it sounds
like the uk is is moving in the right
direction with that with china hopefully
the russia report will
will kind of give you a kick in the
pants with regard to russia although i
have to say
uh if any of my my colleagues who i've
worked with across british government
are listening i do think that you guys
are more with it than than the u.s
government is and you've done a lot of
good work in terms of holding the tech
companies accountable
and you've also done good work in in
europe supporting governments and
organizations that are countering
russian disinformation so it's not all
bad
how much of it is a top-down problem how
much of it is
policy makers need to steam in and say
right you need to show
national certified identification
to start a twitter or facebook account
or you need
do you know what i mean like what what's
the solution here from a policy side
well i will say that i think um
one thing the russia report shows is
that it was successful
administrations and governments in the
uk that kind of dropped the ball
so uh successive rather not successful
successive administrations that dropped
the ball
um and here in the united states we
certainly have a leadership problem uh
trump doesn't want to recognize that
this is a problem
that recognition um whether it's coming
from
uk prime minister u.s president is key
to shoring up the resources that are
necessary
to create a policy response and neither
of our governments have done that
satisfactorily yet
um every country that i look at in the
book who
who at least has that clear assessment
is able to get more done
than both of our governments have so
that's the first thing um
the policy response without getting too
boring and wonky
really has to be whole of government and
that's a term that's thrown around a lot
and i think when most national security
people say whole of government they
they kind of just mean you know we need
that recognition
from from the top and we're gonna have
some meetings about it um when i say
whole of government i mean it really
needs to
include the parts of government that you
don't normally think of as part of the
national security apparatus
uh like we have a department of
education who deals with
schools they need to be in the room
because we need to be teaching kids
media literacy digital literacy how to
recognize when they're being emotionally
manipulated all these things
some countries have like a ministry of
culture ministry of sport
ministry of youth all of those need to
be included
we need to invest more in our public
journalism
i really admire the bbc system i know it
has its faults but
uh you that's a true investment in
journalism as a public good and in the
united states we spend three dollars per
person per year
on uh on our public broadcasting
corporation
i'm gonna say as much as you can
criticize the bbc it is nowhere near as
[ __ ] as america's press presses
oh my god like the last few of the last
few months have been a complete [ __ ]
show
well and you know in uh in times of
crisis i think it's something around 60
percent of brits still trust the bbc
as as a source of information and crisis
and i i can't think of a single source
that americans would trust to that
extent and that's a problem that's
that vacuum is exactly what
disinformation is attacking so
i hope that there is someday a
government that understands that we need
to heal ourselves
at home to deal with these problems that
means good governance it means investing
in education it means investing in
in journalism and empowering the parts
of government that deal with people on a
regular basis local and state
governments again
those those kind of citizen oriented
parts of government like the department
of education um and we've not gotten
there yet and then there's a regulatory
question
that you know congress has completely
dropped the ball in terms of
the the social media regulation we need
and also campaign finance reform which
is
never going to fully be solved because
it it benefits those in power to not
reform campaign finance
um but uh these are all the things that
you know really need a good hard look
and um i'm hoping that when
people go to the ballot box in november
or as it were i suppose mail their
ballots in
uh that we will all be thinking about
that and how we need a renewed
commitment to truth in this country
because
ultimately um without that
volition without that political will and
government we
we can't do very much and then there's
no point in me getting out of bed in the
morning
there's something about the
divisive narrative that i've been
increasingly hearing obviously like 2020
is just
mental that trump got impeached this
year
i know which was 75 years ago
yeah got impeached this year um
tiger king happened this year you know
like the the big the big [ __ ]
it's so divisive like it's it's never
been
as mental for me as a brit to
voyeuristically watch
the slow-motion car crash that is
american press um
but there is some
extra factor of fear
that gets layered over the top of all of
that when you realize that that might
not be
due to the volition of the people
who are actually writing the stories or
that the stories were being written
about stuff which was contrived like
purposefully created by
bad state actor by out-of-state actors
who want
this to be the outcome this is like
i don't know this is like finding out
the monster under your bed isn't what
you need to worry about because the bed
is the monster
you're like oh f
oh like i mean like you you you thought
it was just this and then it turns out
it's like
like the sequel the sequel to the horror
movie is actually where it's like it's
all russia so
i don't know i mean what's the long game
like what's the what's the the real kind
of
end result here obviously it's it would
appear china is raise ourselves up to
look like a stronger superpower
russia is terror the people other
countries down so that we relatively
look stronger
again as you've identified it would
appear that that's because
russia probably has to appreciate its
own glass ceiling it can't pretend to be
a global superpower when it comes to the
tech game
like no one's buying russian iphones um
so um so what's what is the the end
goal for russia then other than just to
make america look a bit [ __ ]
well again i think that has domestic
implications for putin's grip on power
um it's always been about you know
the comparative exercise between russia
and the west and what an authoritarian
system can offer
versus the unpredictability of democracy
if you look at the
arab spring if you look at what happened
in ukraine euro maidan
in in 2013 2014 or even if you go back
further to the revolutions that happened
in georgia and kyrgyzstan in the early
2000s
um that's always been the biggest threat
to putin something that he's always been
scared of sorry nina i love the way that
you say putin
my russianness to me i mean we can say
putin but but that just makes me sound
like i'm from new jersey which i am
[Laughter]
i try not to to you know if you get me
cursing then i really start to sound
like i'm from from new jersey so
we won't do that here uh but uh
but yes so uh that that all benefits
good old vlad
putin um and uh and i think that's the
long game it's to maintain his
his grip on power and then you know also
it puff up
puff up russia which benefits him as
well um
and i i just think it's really important
especially because you know more actors
are are entering the disinformation game
now that the russian playbook has been
opened for everyone to to see
and you know this playbook has been used
by advertisers and pr people
for for ages right um
we just need to again turn inward the
more that we can
heal the fissures in our society provide
good governance
uh create a resilient society one that
is
skeptical but in a healthy way that's
using information to
to create better governance uh teaching
civics really important
um then we're going to be more resilient
if you look at nations like sweden and
finland and estonia
they've invested in these things and
they're all smaller and more homogeneous
nations than the uk or the us but our
countries are also extremely innovative
we're also
you know we're good at this stuff if we
invest in it we just have to recognize
it
and not just play what i call whack a
troll all the time and think that we can
just remove bad accounts remove bad
content and that will fact check our way
out of this crisis of truth and trust
ultimately it's about us it's about all
of us and
we all have to do our part
i don't know i really i really feel like
there's a lot of deceleration that needs
to be done before you can even reverse
the direction of what's going on at the
moment
which is sad right like you write this
book
not knowing that 2020 is going to be
this slow motion pile up
and then and the the parting note is
let's remember our similarities not our
differences let's fix the fishes
let's come together and force
policymakers use our votes etc etc
and what you don't know is that a
like tectonic plate sized chasm is going
to split straight through the middle of
the country
there's going to be and it's going to be
about wearing face masks
amongst amongst many many many other
things um
yeah there needs to be a real change
i think of um attacked especially given
the fact that there's people out there
who really do want the country
the the west generally to fall to pieces
um i wonder whether
there is a a part of the fact that
russia has been the bad guy for so long
and the way that popular media portrays
that
that we've almost caricatured
putin into that like oh better not be
meddling in any of our elections again
vlad
like and you know it's that classic like
almost a sort of a meta character about
what russia is um that is making us kind
of
forget that they're they're genuinely
able to do malicious stuff
whereas i think that might be the reason
that china feels
natively a little bit more scary because
it's a newer threat
like we were used to russia we know
where to put them there in the russia
box
like vlad wears the big fluffy hat and
he rides he rides a horse with his top
off and like that's what he does
um but we we don't know about china and
yet that is exactly the sort of
wolf in sheep's clothing like you don't
need to worry about us situation that
russia would want right to be able to
to really do a lot of damage yeah i
think
it's partly that and partly just that
our conception of russia is grounded in
kind of this cold warrior
thought process and as a young woman in
the russia field
there's nothing that makes me more
annoyed than to walk into a room or as
it were like a zoom call
with a bunch of people who have really
interesting experience but
have never used a facebook account and
uh you know
still conceive of and sometimes slip up
and say the soviet union
instead of russia right it's a different
country um it's a different country and
and
and its people are different the young
people are different i think the the
tactics that the ira uses are a
reflection of that
again a reflection of the weaponization
of our own
openness and there's a
a reluctance to look in the mirror
and say you know that this isn't this
isn't something that russia caused that
it's it's our weakness that's being
being weaponized not just
democratic weaknesses but again these
societal
issues um and i think that's that's
hampering us when we
again because chinese propaganda and
this information is a little bit more
straightforward
it's just easier to be like this is bad
what they're doing is bad
um and and nobody wants that but what
russia is doing is so
clever and uh and it is hard to
attribute like
exactly how bad it is there's always
this ongoing debate about
did russia change any votes and it's
impossible to know that right because we
we can't do retroactive polling and be
like did you see this ad
did it change your vote people don't
that's not how people's thought process
works but it is a steady drip drip over
time that affects public opinion and
people's conception of candidates and
issues during campaign
um and as such you know it makes it
really hard to respond to whether it's
russia or anybody else and so
i don't know i i hope that there is uh
a little bit of return to nuance in the
next couple of months although that's
gonna be hard
nobody's really talking about foreign
policy right now in the united states we
have
bigger fish to fry um and
and i think what little foreign policy
discussion we are going to talk about is
going to be characterized by that same
rancor
and uh and kind of simplicity that
the the past couple of years have been
um and it's just gonna be
you know either you're you're pro
meddling or anti-meddling which is
a really poor distillation of the topic
um but unfortunately that's that's what
it's come down to in washington and a
lot of discussions
i'll have to see how 2020 plays out nina
i think good point to
leave it there what should you what do
you want to plug where where do you want
people to go
oh uh well you should buy my book at
whatever
local bookstore you like i think those
local bookstores need help right now
i understand if you don't want to leave
your house then you can buy it on one of
the online sites but uh
if you can order from your local india i
think that is the
the best thing to do at these difficult
times very cool it will be linked in the
show notes below on amazon or
you know throw a face mask on go to
waterstones use the google machine
you can find it yeah sure uh look nina
thank you i hope that you have
nothing to write about for the rest of
2020 and yet sadly i think that i'm
going to be wrong
probably unfortunately it's great to
talk to you chris
and you
[Music]